en parler il comptait ce membre d'europe
écologie les verts ancien adjoint à la
mairie de paris bons soient ils feront
face aux merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
à vos côtés laurent de la comédie porte
parole du rassemblement national bonsoir
laurent jacot bélie merci d'être avec
nous alors 20 ans on le disait que que
ce problème qui pourrait la vie un des
riverains dur personne manifestement
n'est capable d'y mettre fin tout est la
faute laurent jacobellis d'anne hidalgo
l'état aussi sa part de responsabilité
clairement anne hidalgo a sa part de
responsabilité on la voyait fin juin
dire je verrai les problèmes je vais
nettoyer les lieux je vais proposer des
solutions pour qu'on ait plus ce
terrible spectacle à la vue des familles
et des enfants deux mois plus tard le
problème s'est déplacé de quelques
mètres malheureusement il ya toujours
des scènes dans les rues des scènes de
viols des scènes de prostitution des
scènes de personnes qui vivent comme des
zombies et qui sème le trouble mais on
ne va pas charger anne hidalgo elle
n'était pas encore maire que ça existait
déjà ce sont vingt années de laxisme
vingt années d'incompétence qui se sont
succédé où on a laissé faire car
clairement les malheurs se superposent
aux malheurs le malheur des riverains à
qui on doit s'adresser ce soir quand
même qu'ils vivent dans une république
où il pourrait espérer vivre en paix
vivre paisiblement dans l'ordre
républicain où la police arrête les les
dealers ou la justice les emprisonnent
mais il n'en est rien
il faut aussi dire que les mesures n'ont
pas été prises
les gens qui se droguent je rappelle
quand même c'est une évidence mais que
c'est illégal en france est donc
clairement il faut une double action
envers ces personnes d'abord une action
sanitaire parce que le crack c'est quand
même très violent on a des gens qui
cicatrise mans ont déraillé donc il faut
les aider mais il faut aussi faire
respecter la loi bien rappeler que c'est
interdit et puis les dealers
rien ne doit laisser tolérer le deal il
faut les arrêter le marché du crack à
paris et détenue pratiquement
exclusivement par des sénégalais
en clandestin donc il faut évidemment
les arrêter et les expulser du
territoire les habitants du quartier
payent des impôts ils payent des impôts
pour que la police les protège et que la
justice fasse appliquer les peines ils
ne payent pas d impôt pour qu'on ouvre
des salles de shoot et rajouter de la
drogue à la drogue donc tout ce laxisme
toute cette compréhension tout ce non
respect des lois depuis 20 ans a amené à
une scène indignes de la capitale de la
france et à des riverains qui n'en
peuvent plus qui sont à bout parce
qu'ils voudraient simplement voir que
nous loi seront respectés on va laisser
la parole à l'ats yves contassot
qu'est-ce que vous étiez avoue yves
contassot à la mairie de paris de 2001 à
2008 en charge de l'environnement sont
bertrand
delanoë c'est vrai que ces images sont
édifiants ces témoignages vous comment
vous l'expliquez je vouvoyais voilà
serrer les dents quand vous écoutiez
laurent jacobellis vous n'êtes pas
d'accord manifestement avec ce
diagnostic non mais vous savez la
démagogie il ouvert c'est la faute des
sénégalais etc connais bien c'est un
discours qui malheureusement est
tellement loin de la réalité la réalité
c'est que nous sommes dans un des rares
pays dans lequel il y a ni idéologie
véritablement je dirais
instrumentalisé je donner deux exemples
la cocaïne on n'en parle pas tracks d'un
dérivé de la cocaïne par qui est elle
aujourd'hui consommée par un certain
nombre de responsables politiques de
très haut niveau par un spray sponsors
des responsables du show biz du business
etc on n'en parle jamais jamais c'est
évidemment non peu très peu très peu
tout le monde connaît les noms quasiment
on n'en parle jamais gîtes les témoins y
compris au conseil de paris de seine où
d'anciens ministres étaient
manifestement sous l'emprise de drogues
dures et donc ça c'est 1 tab mais
évidemment c'est plus facile de dire
c'est de la faute de quelques sénégal la
réalité la réalité c'est que à l'autre
extrémité on est dans un déni de la
réalité
du côté des drogues beaucoup moins dure
du cannabis tant qu'on sera dans cette
espèce de folie qui consiste à dire
qu'il faut absolument réprimer interdire
exactement comme à l'époque de la
prohibition de l'alcool aux états unis
ou ailleurs on ne voudra pas voir la
réalité c'est qu'on favorise le dis on
favorise le trafic en pensant réprimer
tout le temps et condamner de manière
indistincte au lieu d'avoir des mesures
de santé publique comme on l'a fait pour
l'alcool et ça a plutôt bien marché
quand on regarde la baisse de la
consommation d'alcool et de l'alcoolisme
je me disais c'est à trouver deux
puisqu'on parlait tout à l'heure voilà
ils n'ont pas pris les mesures et vos
dix doigts il faut prendre des mesures
mais quelle mesure vatican de travailler
il faut travailler dans trois directions
me semble-t-il la première c'est de dire
qu'il faut concentrer les efforts pour
effectivement traquer les dealers les
plus importants et pas à les embêter
comme on le fait aujourd'hui on le voit
les petits dealers qui ne sont que des
exécutants donc ces différentes façons
ils sont arrêtés moi ce que je me trompe
vous avez été sur le terrain on ne les
voit pas ces dealers ils sont sous les
fenêtres mais il voit pas parce que les
frais dealers sont bien impliqués
aujourd'hui les journaux ont fait état
de l'arrestation d'un très très gros
dealer et qui était réfugié aux émirats
et donc on voit bien qu'ils sont pas là
ils sont pas présents évidemment sur le
terrain parce que ça nécessite des
moyens considérables et comment nous met
pas ses moyens à ce qu'on demande aux
forces de police de s'occuper de petits
dealers mais évidemment les gros passe à
travers les mailles du filet donc la
première des choses c'est de légaliser
légaliser le cannabis est pas tombé dans
l'espèce de démagogie de démagogie qui
consiste à dire que il faut pas le faire
plein pays le faut je note d'ailleurs
que monsieur darmanin n'hésite pas à
mentir sur cette question là puisqu'il
prétend que les pays qu'il avait fait
revenir dans l'ariège ce qui est
totalement fou vous êtes cd monde a sion
pour vous lubie soixante huitard c'est
grâce monsieur vous pouvez délire et
soldats du classement rien de seconder
mais maintenant non pas dans ce délire
et le cannabis est moins le cannabis peu
moins de 2 de rage que l'alcool est la
cause n'est pas un cas et à l'orgue et
d'alcon n'est pas maintenant vous allez
messieurs le mien à nous arrêter de
niaiser d'abord monsieur respecte ou
nous mais c'est quand vous n'avez pas la
science infuse vous non plus vous n'êtes
pas qu'un autre n'avait pas le droit la
bien nommée au chili les
agrégés le régime c'est très important l
asie résidence à cela nous montre et je
ne sais pas si j -luc pas contre le
trafic de drogue par l'apologie de la
drogue ce que vous venez de faire
l'apologie une étude des services je
m'en sois j'avais presque est-ce que
vous pouvez écouter de nom quand vous
quand vous mentez je ne vous était pas
alors dites moi ce
n'est que du vent il montre une étude
qui a été faite en australie sur des
consommateurs de cannabis donc les gens
que vous énoncez ceux qui consomment
régulièrement c'était sur des étudiants
en université je crois ceux qui
consommaient régulièrement du cannabis
avait des résultats aux examens 60%
inférieurs à ceux qui n'en consommaient
pas ça un effet destructeur sur la
mémoire sur la capacité cognitive et
sacré notamment des comportements
dépressifs et dans les pires des cajas
aiderait de schizophrénie est ce que
pour expliquer le deal de crack dans
certains quartiers de paris il faut
comme solution autorisé notre jeunesse
sacrifiée notre jeunesse sur l'autel
survient très bien de membres de votre
parti en fumée régulièrement et qu'est
ce que je faisais de votre parti
consomme de la cocaïne dans fumât n'ont
jamais et même temps du pape à wigan a
donc ses actes et ses lattes et je vous
invite monsieur mais si on regarde le
graphique 1 500 emplois nets soit dix
ans connecte les gens de votre parti
qu'est ce que vous racontez nous
travaillons de messieurs mesdames
messieurs en tout cas regardez regardez
c'est trop dit ou
s'écrit donc je suis très attiré de voir
dans quel état c'est et moi je pense aux
riverains mais c'était déjà menées sur
des délits et compte à se regarder ce
fric justement issue du rapport un
observatoire européen des drogues et
toxicomanies vient en 2020 vous voyez
toutes les coupes sont en progression
ces dernières années rue ni cocaïne en
tête problème un vous le disiez yves
contassot de santé publique dont les
politiques doivent clairement prendre
conscience pour 2022 vous en la matière
au rassemblement national quel est votre
programme concret les mesures concrètes
jeu ça fait 20 ans qu'on y est notamment
racing très clair là où je rejoindrai
c'est que toutes les consciences
associant d'autres drogues quelles que
soient les classes sociales quelles que
soient les circuits doivent être
convaincus est qu'il faut combattre de a
à z du petit dealer aux grands un arc
aux trafiquants il faut attaquer les
réseaux financiers qui soutiennent les
trafics d'armes qui sont périphériques
il faut attaquer à 360 degrés quelques
petites opérations ciblées ne suffiront
pas à stopper le phénomène c'est ce que
nous devons faire pour ça il faut bien
sûr des moyens de police mais il faut
derrière une justice implacable moi je
parlais récemment avec des agents
pénitentiaires qui nous expliquait que
depuis leur cellule d khalid géraient
leur trafic on a vu les images de
stalingrad mais on a vu aussi récemment
des images de marseille où il y a
carrément des narcos quartiers au sein
de la ville avec des frontières tenus
par les dealers c'est inacceptable dans
un état de droit donc faire respecter la
loi avoir une justice implacable sur les
dealers et faire en sorte que les flux
financiers qui sont liés soit stoppé la
drogue en france s est pas produit non
non non c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
parce qu'il n'y a pas assez d'équipement
humain malheureusement parce que aussi
la justice derrière est trop laxiste et
qu'il ya une forme de tolérance on l'a
vécu sur ce plateau pour certaines
drogues mais toutes les drogues doivent
être combattus ces 3 milliards de
chiffre d'affaires la drogue en france
c'est 4000 points de deal donc c'est
beaucoup de travail mais ça demande une
vraie volonté c'est pas simplement comme
le fait le président de la république
aux gérard darmanin faire des tweets et
se déplaçait sur place rien n'avait été
fait pendant ce quinquennat et il faut
maintenant changer de braquet et je peux
vous assurer que
votre analyse devant laval l analyse
c'est que d'abord il faut traiter les
vrais problèmes nous vous rappelons le
c'est d'abord un problème de santé
d'ailleurs je note que le responsable du
collectif le disait n'attaque pas les
personnes il dit les pauvres il dit ils
sont dans un état d'abandon ils sont en
demande mais quel est l'état du secteur
psychiatrique en france c'est dramatique
c'est dramatique il n'y a pas de
structure pour accueillir ces personnes
combien nous sommes plutôt d'accord avec
l'idée d'annexer sans restriction
effectivement et on le sait bien les
personnes qui sont dans ces salles de
consommation à moindre risque comme on
le dit il s'agit de progressivement
parce qu'on n'arrive pas il n'y a pas de
produit de substitution
aujourd'hui on craque et donc il faut
les sevrer très progressivement et c'est
ça qui est dramatique c'est qu'on peut
être dans la démagogie dire demain matin
je serais de problème on sait que c'est
pas vrai on sait que ça ne marchera pas
il faut avoir tout ce programme de santé
publique qui consiste à dire la drogue
qui n'a pas d'effet majeur effectivement
comme le cannabis qui d'ailleurs et 2
commencent à utiliser y compris à usage
thérapeutique ce qui prouve bien quand
même qu'il ait pas si dangereux que ça
contrairement à ce qui peut être à
fabuler ici ou là et bien justement il
faut ça le traiter comme d'autres
produits qui sont pas à développer moi
je ne suis pas pour l'usagé du cannabis
en tant que tel pas plus que l'alcool
pas plus que le tabac pas plus que tous
ces produits malheureusement la france
le premier pays consommateur est
championne effectivement déposant des
domaines de canet et pourtant on est de
plus en plus dans la répression ça
marche un mois - donc ça prouve que ça
ne marche pas et à l'autre extrémité
effectivement effectivement il faut
avoir des opérations financières des
opérations de contrôle des gros dealer
de stopper un certain mais ne mélangeons
pas tout c'est d'abord un problème de
santé publique il compris la santé des
riverains qui est mise en cause le range
à combiner le modef impôts non mais très
rapidement on ne luttera pas contre la
drogue soit en facilitant l'accès à la
drogue soit en l'autorisant vous savez
quand on a autorisé le cannabis dans
certains pays il se trouve que le
cannabis des dealers étaient plus dosée
en substance psychotrope que le cannabis
officiel qu'elle danis officielle qui en
plus étaient taxés avec des tva locale
avec des impôts ce qui fait qu'on avait
un marché noir qui a continué notamment
en californie avec de la drogue moins
cher et plus dosée donc plutôt que de
faire un état dit leur laissons à l'état
son rôle de protéger les français de
protéger la jeunesse la drogue c'est
interdit en france et c'est une bonne
chose
n'ajoutons pas les à discussion aux
addictions monsieur soyez responsable
renoncer à sanary et justement il veux
pas instrumentaliser ce malheur des gens
comment les femmes et à des fins
politiques et j'adore c'est sûr
différence entre entre vous monsieur
voulait supprimer le sapin de noël est
autorisée bien non vous êtes dans un
parti absolument folklorique gestion
mais savoir une solution concrète
beaumont voit le résultat c'est que
c'est ce que nous prônons qui est en
train de se mettre en place dans la
plupart des pays comme ici dans ce que
vous dites quelle tristesse bah merci
merci on vous aidera pas d'accord merci
contassot merci également laurent
comédie d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france pour ce débat